welcome everybody i want to start with
something a little different today uh a
judge has rejected a plea deal for the
killers of a mod arberry
which would have seen them spend a lot
of their sentences
in the much less severe conditions of
federal custody rather than state prison
and this is really interesting because
it relates to
the way in which
hate crime laws and sometimes really
serious crimes
can end up with people having an easier
time serving their sentences now but
before we even get in getting into the
details i want to preface this by saying
i'm very much against the idea that
there should be
punishment above and beyond what's
actually prescribed like one thing is we
can talk about sentencing guidelines
should you get x number of years or y
number of years if convicted of certain
crimes but as an example
oftentimes there are some even in my own
audience who sort of take pleasure at
the idea that those convicted of sexual
assault and particular child sexual
assault will receive punishment in
prison
from other prisoners in terms of
violence and even rape above and beyond
the sentence for me that's a failure of
our prison system if our prison system
can't even keep people safe from other
inmates that's a failure it's not
something that i say they're really
going to get what's coming to them
because they're also going to be
attacked or raped in prison so that that
i find that to be completely out of
bounds and really an indictment of our
prison system but
without a doubt
in general
inmates would rather spend time in
federal custody rather than state prison
the conditions generally speaking are
considered to be much less harsh and
severe and that came close to happening
with ahmad r berry's killer so let's
look at this report from cnn a federal
judge monday rejected the plea deal
reached by prosecutors and travis
mcmichael on hate crimes charges so
remember that they were convicted in
georgia travis mcmichael were talking
about here convicted in georgia on state
crimes and then there was also a federal
case that is still in process which
includes hate crime charges the
agreement would have precluded his
federal trial in the killing of a mud
arbory earlier mcmichael had agreed to
plead guilty to a single hate crime
charge interference with rights in
exchange for prosecutors recommending he
serve 30 years in federal prison
under the agreement the 36 year old
mcmichael would have been transferred
from a state prison to federal custody
after completing the federal sentence he
would have been returned to georgia to
finish life in prison without parole
five of the final years would have
counted towards his supervised release
from federal prison u.s district judge
lisa god b wood said she was not
comfortable with these guidelines and
arbory's family also opposed the deal
the judge has been expected to rule sep
had been expected to rule separately on
the same plea deal for gregory mcmichael
but after the judge rejected travis's
deal attorneys for both mcmichaels asked
for more time to decide whether to
change their pleas to guilty the hearing
is next friday the family also was
against this idea
arbory's mother wanda cooper jones was
outraged by the proposal and felt
betrayed by u.s justice department
lawyers she told a state court judge
to give the mike mcmichaels what they
deserve life in prison and urged wood
not to accept the deal quote please
listen to me granting these men their
preferred conditions of confinement
would defeat me it gives them one last
chance to spit in my face after
murdering their son and as as it says
here um these are often called country
clubs these federal prisons they have
better funding they're quote generally
more accommodating um this is one of
those cases where
you and we have to see what ultimately
happens this deal has been rejected we
have to see until something is accepted
we we need to wait before we really
comment this is sort of the opposite of
what hate crimes are supposed hate crime
laws are supposed to do
they did a worse crime
it was motivated by racial hate racial
animus racism one might say and for them
to end up doing easier time in federal
prison defeats the point of these hate
crime laws now your reaction might be
david this is why hate crime laws don't
make sense that's a different argument
and i do believe that when there is
a motivation for a crime that goes above
and beyond the individual but rather to
their membership in a certain group or
class be it based on race or national
origin or
ethnicity or whatever the case may be a
sexual orientation
there is something more insidious about
that because it's a crime not only
against the individual but it's a
warning
uh to others who are members of that
group if their membership in the group
was a factor in the crime so for for me
the issue here is not that hate crime
laws exist although i know some in my
audience disagree with me
but this is an issue
of very specific negotiations where
first you've got the state trial and you
have a verdict and you have a sentence
and then later to say wow this crime is
so bad that there's also a federal case
but the federal case actually leads to a
less severe punishment that seems
backwards and so i'm glad that the judge
rejected this plea deal it wouldn't make
sense to say your crime is so bad that
we're also charging you federally but
you're going to get to do 30 years in a
country club rather than in state prison
i'm all for reforming state prison i'm
all for reforming sentencing guidelines
all of it but when the crime is so
serious that you have state and federal
charges you shouldn't end up with a less
severe punishment
thanks to having a federal case so we're
going to continue
watching it and we'll see ultimately
what is accepted i'm curious to hear
from you about this one
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chili sleep which
makes customizable climate controlled
sleep solutions to sleep better their
flagship products are the uhler sleep
system and the cube sleep system which
is what i have both are hydro powered
temperature controlled luxury mattress
pads you can make them as cold as 55
degrees fahrenheit if you wanted you
could go as hot as 115 degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleep's
weighted chilly blanket which keeps you
cold on top too and for a limited time
chilly sleep has a special offer just
for my audience go to chilisleep.com
pacman to learn about the exclusive
discount the link is down below